En 2014, les archéologues ont découvert à Lavau, dans l’Aube,
une tombe princière du Ve siècle avant notre ère.
Un site exceptionnel où, sous un tumulus de 40 mètres de diamètre,
reposait un homme avec son char, un immense chaudron de bronze, de la vaisselle grecque, des bijoux en or et un couteau dans son fourreau.
Mais-que-s’est-il-passé ?
Puisqu’on réfléchit ici à ce qu’est une révolution,
on va s'intéresser à une révolution perçue comme uniquement technologique mais qui a eu des répercussions sociales énormes,
la métallurgie.
Je vais vous expliquer en quelques minutes comment son apparition a très rapidement divisé nos sociétés.
Évidemment pas besoin nécessairement de métal pour se taper sur la gueule, le silex a fait ses preuves chez nos ancêtres préhistoriques.
On constate néanmoins au quatrième et troisième millénaire un changement radical
dans le système de production, de commerce et de sépulture au moment de la diffusion des métaux.
on appelle ces périodes l’âge du Bronze suivie de l’âge du Fer.
Mais comme toutes les innovations techniques, elles se forgent
(tu l’as ?)
sur le temps long depuis le Néolithique.
Au Proche-Orient, on a trouvé les premiers instruments de cuivre natif
à Cayônù Tepesi près d'Ergani en Turquie.
Leur datation se situe entre 7250 et 6750 avant notre ère.
En Europe, il faut attendre le milieu du cinquième millénaire pour voir les premiers centres métallurgiques
et il faut croire que dans certains lieux l’or coule à flots.
En Bulgarie, dans la nécropole de Varna,
on a découvert 3000 objets précieux pour un total de 6 kilos d’or.
Dans les publications, on lit que l’invention de la métallurgie aurait permis la naissance d’immenses réseaux de distribution,
de pouvoirs politiques forts et de très grandes inégalités sociales.
Mais c’est un raccourci.
Rien de tout cela n’est à proprement parler, né avec la métallurgie.
Tout est plus visible, tout s’accentue, ça oui,
mais on connaissait déjà ça au Néolithique.
Si on reste sur les réseaux commerciaux,
on sait que des marchands de Sardaigne rejoignaient régulièrement le continent pour échanger de l’obsidienne.
C’est une roche… d’ailleurs, je l’ai là, l’obsidienne.
L’obsidienne, une roche noire translucide vachement jolie.
On sait aussi que des haches taillées dans le nord de l’Italie ont été acheminées jusqu’en Écosse.
Bref, l’invention du métal ne transforme pas la nature des relations humaines,
mais leur degré d’intensité.
Voilà… à plus.
Non, en vrai, ça a changé pas mal de trucs.
On ne sait pas précisément pourquoi, ni comment,
en quelques siècles cette production a connu un essor considérable.
Les répercussions sur les sociétés ont été énormes
avec l’apparition d'une aristocratie forte.
Avec le métal, les mecs sont devenus riches, beaucoup plus riches.
À Varna, le site dont je vous parlais juste avant,
l'une des tombes renfermait des pendentifs, des perles, des céramiques plaquées or et même des étuis péniens.
Un total de 4320 éléments en or, soit 1518 grammes pour une seule personne !
Comme souvent en archéologie, ce qui nous parvient, ce sont les biens des élites dont on retrouve les instruments et les parures.
Car, et c'est valable pour toutes les cultures et toutes les époques, les objets de prestiges sont des marqueurs sociaux.
Ces « nouveaux riches » font brusquement de très grands profits comme jamais il n'y en avait eu auparavant
en attirant vers leur cité des artisans bronziers et des forgerons.
Cette révolution technologique est à la base des axes commerciaux de l'Europe telle qu’on la connaît aujourd'hui,
mais également des rapports mercantiles modernes.
Il semblerait qu’en inventant la métallurgie,
les humains aient inventé le modèle politique de type chefferie.
Dans cette logique, plus la technique de la métallurgie s'améliore
plus grande est la pyramide sociale et plus fortes sont les inégalités.
La distinction entre pauvres et riches se voit particulièrement dans le contexte funéraire.
En France, dès le IIIe millénaire avant notre ère,
des personnalités de haut rang centralisent les richesses et se font bâtir des tombeaux immenses.
C’est ce qu’on appelle des « tombes princières », meilleur témoin de cette révolution.
Logé dans un tumulus, le mort est entouré de biens de prestige, rares et exotiques.
Haches, hallebardes, poignards, torque, anneaux d'oreilles, etc., etc.
Parfois d’autres sépultures plus discrètes, classées par rang et par genre,
entouraient le tumulus principal.
Les archéologues voient dans ces pratiques funéraires le miroir des inégalités entre individus.
Mais encore une fois, les inégalités existaient bien avant,
il n’y a pas eu le paradis du chasseur cueilleur et puis d’un coup la guerre.
Vous l’aurez compris, avec le métal, on peut s'identifier et se distinguer socialement
que ce soit de son vivant ou même dans l'au delà.
Ce ne sont pas des objets du quotidien, du domestique qui accompagnent à présent les morts,
mais des armes pour souligner leur position sociale.
Mais est-ce que cette affirmation sera toujours valable ?
Cette question m’est venue quand Viviane a expliqué que l’impression 3D devenait une technologie exploitable par tous.
Et dans ce contexte, on peut se demander si les armes échappent à ce système.
Ça, tu vois, c’est un fichier qui a été créé par un américain,
Cody Wilson il s’appelle.
Et le gouvernement tente un peu de le bloquer, parce qu’il a mis une arme en ligne à disposition.
Donc forcément le gouvernement essaie d’enlever le fichier.
Mais tu ne peux pas vraiment confisquer un fichier, comment tu veux faire ?
La seconde où le gouvernement le prend, il y aura forcément une autre personne qui va le mettre en ligne.
Ce doit être la première fois, je pense, dans l’histoire de l’humanité où y a ça qui se passe.
Parce que, par exemple, en archéo, on voit bien que jusqu’à présent, les armes,
les armes en métal, c’est vraiment la propriété des riches.
Une aristocratie qui est très riche qui peut se permettre et qui a les moyens de se payer des armes.
Et d’ailleurs, c’est tellement précieux qu’ils s’enterrent avec, les mecs.
Ah ouais !
Alors que eux là, on va les enterrer avec des manettes.
Gngngngn
Si le premier métal est donc un élément de ségrégation et de cloisonnement social
entre pauvres et riches,
il l’est aussi entre hommes et femmes.
même si on connaît beaucoup de sépultures de femme, comme la très riche tombe de Vix,
la maîtrise du nouveau métal est surtout à l'avantage des hommes.
Haches, poignards, outils agricoles permettent d'asseoir une certaine supériorité masculine.
Les stèles et statues-menhirs nous en apprennent beaucoup sur les transformations sociales opérées par l'avènement de la métallurgie.
Ces statues menhirs représentent un héros, un ancêtre ou un personnage charismatique et joue le rôle de blason familial.
Les femmes y sont symbolisées par leur poitrine, par des accessoires de parure,
les hommes, eux, portent des armes (des arcs, des flèches, des haches mais surtout des poignards).
Ce sont donc des accessoires qui permettent de déterminer le genre et le sexe ne figure jamais sur les représentations artistiques.
Un peu comme Barbie et Ken !
Si on suit cette logique, les femmes sont déterminées par des caractères biologiques et naturels
que sont les seins et les hommes par des armes c'est à dire des productions culturelles !
Alors, on ne peut sans doute pas mettre de côté la question esthétique parce que franchement, la poitrine, on dira ce qu’on voudra, c’est canon,
et peut-être que c’est tout ce qui comptait.
Bref, ce grand « progrès » technique a finalement été un instrument pour renforcer une forme de domination,
celle des hommes sur les femmes, et des riches sur... tous les autres.
Pour un archéologue c’est cette transformation des structures sociales qui est importante,
pas qu’on abatte un arbre avec une hache en bronze plutôt qu’en fer, ça c’est anecdotique.
C’est la fin de cette épisode, merci à tous de l’avoir regardé.
Vous pouvez vous abonner, laisser un commentaire, laisser un pouce bleu.
Et puis n’oubliez pas, on a un Discord sur lequel on peut se retrouver pour discuter et échanger sur cette série.
Salut, à la prochaine !